in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I help some content streamers
figure out their optimal window sizes
well we fetched the right solution stay
tuned to find out for the internet video
streaming company mega streams the most
critical aspect of their operation is
the sweet spot between user connection
speed cloud hosting performance and the
window size you use to buffer and
request data their current architecture
is serving video data directly from
Google Cloud Storage buckets to users on
mobile and desktop devices over the past
month they've been trying to figure out
the right way to duplicate their content
and optimize their window sizes so they
can ensure consistent buffering to their
clients across the US and EU which we
can help them figure out by profiling
how the read performance adjusts at
various window sizes of download to
figure this out I wrote a very simple
script which creates a regional bucket
creates a bunch of files at a bunch of
different file sizes and uploads to that
bucket and then downloads each one of
those files a hundred times via HTTP
fetch with caching disabled that's
important to note this graph shows the
50th percentile for those times and that
4 fetches under one megabyte we can see
very consistent read performance but one
graph never tells the complete stories
so we can switch our test just slightly
to get a better view of things let's
take an 8 megabyte file and fetch it
through different sized chunks this
graph helps us see our read performance
from another perspective as the chunk
size decreases the overhead per
transaction increases thus making things
slower combined these two graphs
illustrate something important now I'm
much like right throughput GCS is
extremely strong in terms of single
stream throughput which means that for
both uploads and downloads GCS is at its
best performance when you're favoring
larger requests about one megabyte in
size otherwise the per transaction
overhead of the requests themselves will
start to slow things down for mega
streams this was a massively helpful
piece of data they now had the ability
to determine what level of regional
redundancy they needed for serving their
video content in order to optimize the 1
megabyte GCS target to improve buffering
speeds data saves the day to learn more
about how
megha streams improve their upload
performance check out the Related
article linked in the description below
and don't forget to check out the rest
of our cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts